this is a production of cornell
university
thanks for having me i really appreciate
a chance to come up here i've been
enjoying
the last couple years i've been
collaborating a bunch with the ryan lab
and so that's been a lot of fun and a
lot of interesting research thrusts and
and so today's talk is to give you a
little bit of a taste of of some of the
work we're doing in beltsville uh
particularly in the development of of
high residue no-till grain production
systems uh we'll give you a a taste of
what's going on down there try to link
it to some of the things that are going
on up here uh reality is obviously we
have some climatic differences so we
have a little more flexibility in
maryland with some of the work we do
with corn particularly
so that's kind of why i focused on corn
was because i think that would be a
little bit something new for you guys in
in this department uh these high residue
no-till corn production systems where i
i take it you probably hear a lot about
soybeans
so this is an ambitious title and like
in every ambitious title not everything
in the title might be in the
presentation so there's a few little
missing details just because uh uh i
wanted to kind of uh cover a wide swath
of things so so you know not everything
in the talk is going to cover
conventional and organic in fact most of
it is going to be around conventional
systems and i'll try to make some
linkages to the implications in organic
as well
so this is really what's been driving
conservation for so long now right the
dust bowl came and since then there's
been just a suite of various different
strategies uh in agriculture to to
conserve soil resources and and this is
an
ongoing dialogue for some time now
certainly uh no-till agriculture has
been one of the dominant strategies to
address uh soil erosion and and and to
conserve those soil resources
organic agriculture has its own paradigm
in which it tries to address soil
conservation in the building of soil
health as well and and so there's this
kind of linkage between these two
systems in that they're both very soil
centric and soil management centric uh
no-till being this cadillac in in
reducing erosion
from the standpoint of you know
improving you know water infiltration
uh increasing uh soil organic matter uh
again reducing the erosion and obviously
why one of the reasons this has taken
off so dramatically and this is just a
distribution of of no-till ground in the
country and
this is 30 for the mid-south so this is
30 and these regions here are 25 to 30
percent reason this has taken off so
rapidly
is because farmers can dramatically save
the amount of time the amount of labor
uh they can cover fields really rapidly
with machinery they're not you know
they're not running machinery through
the soil and so that's certainly been a
huge advantage but there's there's a
challenges associated with no-till
agriculture
um if you look at this fig this uh map
here this is a map of herbicide
resistance you know so this is
particularly glyphosate resistant
species across the us and well in
actually part of canada and if you look
this tracks pretty closely to the areas
that are dominated by no-till
agriculture right so so there's this
paradox in in our management between
practices that really conserve our soil
resources uh with practices that
result in some new challenges and some
new management constraints and so while
we're really excited what we can do with
no-till agriculture
herbicide resistance for example has
really challenged our current world view
when it comes to no-till agriculture and
so how do we address that and and and
and look at you can just see the rise
over the years and they might have
unique cases of herbicide resistance so
it's it's a it's a real issue for
conventional agriculture and in the
state of in organic agriculture weeds
are also a real problem in that system
and and particularly as organic
producers who historically have not been
reduced till or no start to try to
reduce tillage in their systems weeds
become even more problematic so weeds
really are at the center of this
challenge in conserving soil resources
and both of these types of systems
so the typical approach right is to
diversify our chemistries stack genes
that's kind of historically how we try
to address resistance and that's
certainly a very important aspect of
weed control and moving forward with
herbicide resistance issues but there's
other strategies there's a lot of folks
emphasizing integrated weed management
practices and this is by no means a
laundry list but it gives you a some
sample of the types of practices that we
target to
both
address we concerns in the system while
trying to conserve some of these
practices like no-till agriculture and
so the remainder of my talk is really
going to focus on these types of
practices and how we can particularly
manipulate cover crops in the system to
you know enable us to continue towards
these uh no these goals with soul
conservation and no-till agriculture
of course no talk would be complete
without mentioning cover crops without
going through all the list of services
that they provide certainly not a
laundry list but
there's a wide range of services that
cover crops provide they're
multifunctional tools and that's why
they fit well into kind of these
no-till systems or as a way of kind of
helping to inhibit or suppress weeds
as well as provide another number of
services in the system
so this is what we've been focusing on
for a number of years and when i say we
really this has been a collective effort
for some time now
folks throughout the whole mid-atlantic
and northeast region have had a really
great synergy and interactions and the
development of these high-residue
no-till systems many folks at cornell
have been key players and this certainly
i know a big influence to everything
i've done in these systems and all the
work that we've done over the years have
really come from chuck's early work with
john teasdale and all of those uh
questions they asked related to how
different mulch elements suppress weeds
and so what you're seeing now is kind of
where we've been taking that work and
how we've been trying to operationalize
that into production grain production
systems and so we've been historically
using a lot of rye and soybean systems
and hairy vetch and corn
this varies there's a lot of interest in
other cereals and other legumes for a
number of reasons but i'm going to just
focus on these these two cover crops
today and looking at them as in
monoculture and in mixture
most of you are probably familiar with
this piece of equipment at this point by
now and this is simply a tool that has
helped really operationalize our ability
to do uh uh
high residue no-till production systems
with cover crops because it's a way of
rapidly knocking down cover crops and
enabling us to plant cash crops behind
that and whether or not you're spraying
your cover crop and then rolling it down
to make a mulch that suppresses weeds or
whether you're killing it
effectively with the roller crimper in
an organic system both have the same
implications in the standpoint of of
creating this this uniform uh mulch mat
and this just gives you a a taste of
what some of this looks like and and and
the kind of residues that we're working
with
so what i'd like to first do is talk a
little bit about the equipment end of
things that's really where a lot of the
learning has been over the last decade
we've
implemented a host of biological studies
looking at interactions between weeds
and cover crops and cover crops and
fertility management but one of the the
constraints that's really
made it difficult for us to take this
from something that we're evaluating on
a research station to recommending to
producers is our ability to get
uniform populations of our crops in the
field and regardless of the conditions
of the cover crop and so i'm just going
to briefly review some of those
approaches
so we we certainly find planters to be
much more effective than drills you have
less steel that's going through the
field and so you you can get better
downward pressure and and the planter
certainly has better simulation of seed
and placement of that seed and so that's
been a big step forward for us we're
early years we're focusing on drills
particularly with soybeans
soil moisture content and weight is a
huge component of the efficacy of our
ability to cut residue and get seed into
the ground and so that's something that
we've looked at a lot over the years
when the residue is too wet sometimes
it's hard to to cut and it can get
pushed down into the ground and that
particularly applies to the soil if the
soil is is really wet then it's not firm
enough to provide that resistance to get
good cutting action with our coulters
and so there we don't get good cutting
of the residue when you don't cut the
residue the planter just rides up on the
ground and you deliver a nice row of
seeds all along the surface of the
ground and you don't get your crops so
this is a real big issue
uh residue quality i just mentioned a
little bit about that so we've been
playing a lot with timing of rolling
with timing of planting and the
combinations of those practices i'm not
really going to focus a lot on that in
this talk but we have a number of papers
over the years that have come out to it
that have addressed that issue and we
feel like we have a better handle now on
just the the interaction between when we
kill and when we plant and what the
residue quality needs to be and what the
soil conditions need to be
colder types generally we've been
focusing mostly with on on using these
type of ripple or bubble cultures
anything that has a wavy fluted edge on
it just creates more surface area to go
through that residue and and more
cutting action that has to occur and so
there haven't been really effective uh
folks like these different bubble or
ripper ripple or straight cultures for
various reasons due to soil texture and
and and uh what they're doing in their
individual operations but generally you
want a straight edge on that end to get
good cutting
closing wheels have been another another
issue that we've dealt with over the
years and what we're moving towards is
more of these curved tines coupled with
like either cast iron or rubber uh discs
because we get not only better closure
but you get some crumbling more of the
soil so that you get more seed to soil
contact so that's kind of the name of
the game in this right is is both being
able to cut through the residue that's
goal one and then after you cut through
that residue being able to uh get good
firming and seed soil contact around
your crop seed
and so these are some of the new
planters now that we're we're working
with we're working with planters that
have trash wheels like the shark tooth
out the front to either
totally remove or just partially remove
the residues in the front of these
coulters and then we have these heavy
residue slicers that come in behind that
to cut that residue to make sure that
it's clean and then we let the normal
planter configurations which is back
here do their usual work and they're not
dealing with the same amount of residue
as these front units are and so we
basically add another toolbar in front
of our planter just to address these
issues
okay enough with the uh machinery talk
i'm not an ag engineer so i i don't have
a lot more to say about that that's some
of the discoveries that we've had over
the years uh we're going to talk a bit
more about the biology and and
particularly focus on
managing cover crops for improving
the
persistence of the residues that we have
out there
for better weed suppression and then
trying to improve our nutrient
management and that's really been the
challenge in corn with soybeans we're
all focused on just getting big cereals
out there so that we can suppress a lot
of weeds and we have a
fixing a nitrogen fixing cash crop so
nitrogen isn't an issue for us really
when we're balancing both nitrogen and
weeds in these systems regardless of
whether they're conventional or organic
that's when it becomes a bit more
challenging
and so that's why there's been a lot of
interest in combining cover crops you
know you can get the benefits of grasses
which are highly weed suppressive they
don't produce a lot of nitrogen
with legumes that do produce a lot of
nitrogen but are not as weed suppressive
and so
the focus on combining these into
mixtures and trying to identify what are
these optimal configurations depending
on your production your production goals
is is a big part of
getting optimal performance out of our
cover crops and having a consistency
from year to year
so uh these are the the themes that i
think are important to cover from your
ideal cover crop mixture for no-till
corn right we want something that is
going to produce a lot of biomass so
both it has the potential for
suppressing weeds but that it also
produces a lot of biomass and which
translates into more nitrogen content
that it you know slow res residue decay
which also translates into better
synchrony of the release of that
nitrogen with crop uptake and so i'm
going to kind of cover these different
themes now in the next set of slides
so this is an experiment which we
establish and we've had about four years
of this experiment and we've conducted
this and we're it's done now we're not
it's we just finished it last year and
we did this on two replicated sites that
have fairly similar soil types we did
this on a certified organic field that's
been certified organic since 2000 and we
did it on a site that receives a lot of
the kinds of
diverse amendments and and cover crop
practicing uh has similar crop rotations
but is managed conventionally so they
have a lot of similarities in their
management history the commodities that
are in those systems like corn soybean
wheat rotation uh and and and in this in
this uh
in these two sites we created
essentially at a continuum of cover crop
uh mixture proportions so here is our
our cover crop mixture proportions from
a zero uh percent uh vetch all the way
to 100 veg and vice versa the 0 100
uh yeah i'm sorry doing that wrong here
so this is 100 vetch and this is 100 rye
and these are just
in a replacement series design based on
uh
maximum seating rates
of the monocultures
and so first let's look at some of the
biomass so here we these are collected
in half meter squared frames uh and they
were they're collected actually in every
single fertility treatment which i
haven't described yet so there's a whole
host of fertility treatments layered on
top of this and we took cover crop data
for every one of those points so our
biomass that you're looking at right now
is a tremendous amount of samples that
are in those because the fertility
treatments haven't been imposed yet
because we haven't killed the cover crop
uh yet but so when we're taking that
biomass samples we have quite a bit of
data that goes into these figures and so
what i want to introduce you to is just
a simple replacement series design where
you're looking at in this case a hairy
vetch cereal rye seeding rates so these
are our categorical treatments these are
actual just treatments that we imposed
out there and you're moving from
zero to a hundred percent vetch and you
can see here here's the vetch going up
here's the rye going up this direction
and this is the total biomass
so we're going to look at this in a
little bit more
that was exactly what i shouldn't do
there we go
um so this is a
a model that has had a lot of use over
the years to look at plant interactions
and plant competition it's a dewitt
model uh if you want more details about
this model you can look here i'm not
going to go into every aspect the nuance
of this model but just conveying that
essentially you're looking at how these
species perform in monoculture as as
compared to how they behave in mixture
and then the interactions of those uh
across these different seating rates and
then
the total model
represents the addition of these two
independent models
so again vetch is going up rye is going
to the left
and this is our monoculture biomass of
rye and this is our monoculture biomass
of etch and this solid line represents
total biomass
one of the reasons folks use this kind
of design
is because it is a useful way for
looking at over yielding so do the uh
combination of these two cover crops
produce more biomass than the sum of the
parts so to speak and and so there's a
lot of interest in over yielding for a
number of reasons and like such as in
polycultures inter-cropping systems and
in this case we're looking at it in the
case of cover crop performance
and so now all i've done is just taken
that one figure and show you the extent
of the data sets we have so this is the
north farm our organic site which tend
to have much higher uh soil fertility or
at least uh
typically does than on the south farm
which again similar soil types
but um uh one is conventional one is
organic and what you're looking at here
are uh three site years of data done
where both of these different cover
crops were established about very
similar time frame uh in in fields that
are not very far apart so climate is not
very different between these fields
but what i really want to cue you into
is just look at how strikingly different
the behavior of the species are like for
example here where harry vetch is not
very competitive early on and there's a
real lag and rye is extremely
competitive and dominates compared to a
system like this where vetch is
increasing biomass rapidly
so there's a lot of factors that go into
cover crop performance and i think
you know there's a lot of things we can
we can talk about in this figure the key
points here just that where these plus
signs are were years where we saw over
yielding
but what i really want you to queue into
is just how much variability there is in
these six site years
and there's a lot of factors that go
into cover crop performance and when
we're trying to get producers to use
cover crops
you know a big issue with using cover
crops is the consistency and precision
in which you can use these cover crops
in your production system and so part of
using mixtures is a way of kind of
reducing some of that variability
because of the plasticity of the two
species but even within just these two
species you can just see on sites that
tend to have a little bit more nitrogen
for example such as as these fields here
where the rye really dominated versus
sites that were a lower nitrogen levels
you can see big differences in just the
growth rates of the individual species
now we're taking this uh same uh
set of samples and we're analyzing it
for an uh nitrogen content and so this
is just one of those many site years
that we're just looking at
and now we're looking at total end
content we're looking at end content in
the veg and then content in the rye and
this is across this proportion gradient
but now whereas before we had
categorical treatments
now we're using the raw data whereas the
biomass that we actually harvested out
in the field
that just because we put out an 80 20
percent mix of ryan vetch doesn't mean
we ended up with exactly an 80 20 mix so
this is the real distribution of
biomass in amongst those species in the
field and now let's kind of look at this
point here
you can see that and so this is
monoculture legume biomass
and that's how much i mean nitrogen
content not biomass sorry so this is how
much nitrogen we can produce
with the legume in monoculture
and what i want you to look at is this
region of missing information so this
isn't missing information this is
every year we put out
these different
experiments and some years
vets biomass dominated more and we were
able to span that region in other years
we didn't and you can see how how much
less veg biomass that we had and the raw
i tended to dominate
but what you can see is generally
despite that at our 50 mixtures or when
we start to get above a certain
threshold we notice that this solid line
that's the total nitrogen of the entire
cover crop that tends to be equivalent
to your legume biomass and monoculture
and legume nitrogen content in
monoculture so the idea is you're trying
to find that threshold where the end
content in your mixture
is equivalent to the end content in your
monoculture of your legume
and so when we look go back to this same
set of slides now here's the all six
site years in this data set as well as
data published data sets uh all over the
country we did a meta-analysis this was
presented at the last tri-society
meeting of mixtures versus monocultures
and the trends that we see both in our
data sets as well as across the
literature are some key points that uh i
think are worth mentioning one we
generally do see over yielding with
mixtures of grass legume cover crops
particularly in this case rye hairy
vetch so we do tend to get that greater
biomass production and mixture and that
generally when your legume
is 50 of the composition of the total
biomass and mixture that's when we get
to about that threshold in total end
content
and so just there alone if we're asking
quite if we if there's objectives with
having more grass in the mixture well
depending on what you're targeting
whether your nitrogen needs or weed
needs you might want to find yourself on
a different part of this trajectory
based on your your management objectives
so that really will depend on a given
farmer and so what we're trying to do is
just lay out the spectrum of potential
that's out there and and producers would
have to make those choices based on
their needs
and what the major factors we found
contributing to that uh this over
yielding uh are are really the
proportion of the cover crop and seeding
rate applied and gdd and what was really
interesting most experiments that have
over yielding of cover crops are not
when they're doing a replacement series
like us where we're actually decreasing
the seeding rate of one species for the
rate of another a lot of folks who are
working with mixtures are finding uh
this over yielding where they're having
higher seeding rates than what would be
the equivalent of a a one species
seeding rate
relative to the two species
so uh summary with those uh set of
figures that we looked at uh you can
achieve equivalent or greater biomass
than monocultures celerial rye tends to
dominate in our sites now maybe that's
because we have a history of manure
management a history of cover cropping
and soil conservation in our research
sites that we have a little bit higher
mineral mineral end than if you're going
to some of your sandier sites or or or
lower fertile sites but generally rye
dominates because of that excess
nitrogen availability and again what i
mentioned about the plateau at 50
percent hairy vetch biomass
so now
we follow this up with a decomposition
study looking at the release of
the decay of that cover crop biomass as
well as the release of nitrogen into the
soil and so here we're using litter bags
to do that and these are the proportions
we targeted so slightly different before
we were looking at six different cover
crop mixtures we replaced some of them
and just went to 25 75s and 50 50s
because it's a lot of work to do these
little bag studies
so i'm going to introduce you an
exponential decay model many of you are
familiar with this this is one of the
most common models that we use in
agricultural sciences for those who are
not uh cue into both the p and the k
because those are the two coefficients
that really that were that we're going
to be talking about quite a bit uh this
is somewhat almost of a double
exponential so for those of you not
familiar the main exponential model
decay models right here and this kind of
allows for some slower pool decay that
i'm not going to go into much discussion
about that but but just to give you a
little taste of folks have understanding
what they're looking at here if you hold
k constant which is our decay rate and
you vary p
this is our pool size so the the
distance the the difference between
these asymptotes represent the pool size
whether that's the pool of nitrogen or
the total amount of biomass that was
lost from the system
that's our pool size and so that's what
happens when you vary p when you vary k
that affects the shape of that decay the
rate of decay in in this model and so
what the next set of models we look at
are you're going to see differences in p
and k
and that's what's driving the
differences in the relationships of
these cover crop in their biomass
decomposition and then release
so here you're you're starting to get
familiar uh with uh uh the the various
different data sets we have here this is
the serial rye at the top this is hairy
vetch at the bottom so this is just
a decrease in
cereal rye and an increase in hairy
vetch as you go down and
as you'd expect as you increase hairy
vetch into the mixture you have a faster
decay rate
or you have a greater amount of decay
that mat for that matter and so what
we're generally seeing is an increase
as you increase hairy vetch proportion
you have an increase in the proportional
loss
and so that proportion loss is p
so that's just the total amount of
biomass in this case and another slide
would be the total amount of nitrogen
we also find uh that as you increase
hairy vetch proportion the you have an
increase in the rate of loss so in this
case you both have a rate
and a pool size change in the decay of
these cover crops across these mixtures
and we have a fair amount of variability
as you expect from year to year and uh
we're this is this kind of work we're
actually working with um the adapt end
folks and jeff melkonian on on uh
calibrating some of the models using
adapt end to estimate nitrogen release
and uptake and so this is the kind of
issue that we have to address that
there's just annual variations right
that this this year you had faster rates
of decay than this year and as you might
expect there were differences in
precipitation that year so we had just
it was just
a little bit more moist out there cover
crops decay better when they're wet then
when they're dry and and so being able
to build models that incorporate uh this
type of variability is important so that
we can make
models that would be able to extend
across broad regions and useful for
estimating and release
okay now we're going to look at
synchrony of release with crop demand
how are we doing time-wise
okay good all right great
so now we've looked at
how cover crop composition affects
biomass
the nitrogen content and even it's its
uh uh
decomposition of the biomass now we're
going to look at some of the nitrogen
dynamics so one of the reasons why we're
so interested in release rates and
decomposition of cover crops and how
we manage cover crops may influence
those rates
is because
we're trying to increase our use
efficiency of nutrients in our system
generally all any good you know uh
sustainable and conservative corn
management uh system is going to target
trying to improve nitrogen use
efficiency so the amount of nitrogen you
put out in the landscape you recapture
as much as that as possible back into
that cash crop and so in the case of
corn you can see when it starts to reach
exponential uptake of nitrogen that
happens around at v5 v8 and so that's
why we have a standard practice in
conventional agriculture to side dress
our corn and split our applications
amongst nitrogen put down at starter
versus at side dress so that we're not
dumping all our nitrogen out in the
field when there's nothing to take it up
and and we lose a lot of that nitrogen
early in the season
and what's interesting is that you know
we are always so focused on good
synchrony of n with
with our
crop uptake from mineral fertilizer
standpoint but we really
understate how much
available nitrogen comes from a legume
from the moment that it's it's
terminated it releases nitrogen very
rapidly and we have lots of nitrogen uh
leaching concerns and and potential
coming from a legume so that's why these
mixtures really provide a lot of
opportunity to manage that and so here
again you're looking at uh you don't ry
is not modeled here because we couldn't
fit a model to that because there really
was no
uh uh change in and and and
um and that and that could be both a
combination of of and uh not no loss of
nitrogen or what what's more common to
happen is not only are you losing some
nitrogen from the rye but rye is also a
sink for
fungal mediated nitrogen translocation
from the soil into the mulch above the
ground and so the nitrogen somewhat
cycling and stored in there but you can
see between 2012 and 13 while we did
have some differences the big thing that
stands out obviously is that the rate of
release of nitrogen is really rapid in
these monocultures and that as we
add grass into this mix we delay the
release of that nitrogen now we're not
just delaying the release of that
nitrogen we're also doing something else
where
we're decreasing the pool size right so
that these this dirt this is this is our
decay constant but this is our pool size
and so while we're slowing down the
release of nitrogen to get better
synchrony we're reducing how much
nitrogen that's going to the cash crop
which poses a management challenge right
because we want to hit our yields goal
and make sure we have enough nitrogen
out there
in this case though increasing hairy
vetch proportion
resulted in an increased proportion of
end loss but
whenever we had a grass and a doom
together there was not much of a change
in the rate so the pool size differed
how much we total nitrogen was released
but the rate of release was was was comp
was similar
and this is really just a repeat of what
i just said
so increasing hairy vetch composition in
the mixture
resulted in a proportion of mass loss of
the p
a proportion of n loss so both that
again that p constant and then the rate
of mass loss during corn growing season
so that's just the biomass had a decay
rate difference but not so much in the
form of nitrogen release when legumes
were with grasses and mixture
now this is just a yield response from
across the mixture so this is no
additional fertility applied but you can
see that we can get almost 90 bushels
difference when going from a pure grass
to a pure legume and our corn green
yields so the cover crops are certainly
providing a huge impact on the
performance of our cash crop but as i
mentioned before particularly as we move
towards mixtures that have a lot of
advantages we're reducing the amount of
nitrogen in the system and so we need
more nitrogen
this can come in on a range of different
sources for conventional producers
mineral fertilizer is certainly the the
easiest option putting down
u a n is is some of the treatments we do
have in this experiment i'm not going to
highlight that a big issue in our region
as is in your region is animal waste uh
we deal with more poultry litter than
you guys you guys deal with dairy but
again uh that it's a big uh management
issue and so getting a manure into the
system to supplement the nitrogen needs
uh with with our cover crop it was one
of our objectives um and and you can see
here uh that these are being surface
applied when we surface apply we lose a
lot of our nitrogen in in the form of it
volatilizes and plus you also are have
some risk of of erosion as well and so
surface applications is is is really uh
you know
been a a
challenge to get past it's been decades
worth of research and effort by both
farmers and researchers to develop
technology to address that issue uh
liquid dairy manure has certainly seen
the the fastest um progression in that
just because it's easier to work with
liquids
in maryland this is really heightened
for us because we have more and more
restrictions coming out for example we
have to now have any kind of animal
waste incorporated within 48 hours of
application
so there's a lot of interest in trying
to incorporate animal waste uh as a
source of fertility rather than uh
applying it on the surface or applying
another surface and incorporating
through tillage just because of the
obvious concerns we expressed about
tillage
and so these are some of the prototypes
that folks have developed over the years
to
to test this question these are small
plot units this can
this has been used in both pastures as
well as production systems mostly
pre-plant type of applications so we we
were kind of excited about that you know
it was it seemed like some opportunity
here people are starting to work with
poultry litter these dry solids to get
them incorporated and so i kind of
shopped around and looked at some
products that that might work for us uh
we're not ag engineers we're not
interested in in developing ready
technology for farmers to adopt we're
biologists so we're going to test how
this behaves how we can increase use
efficiency of nutrients and and what are
the benefits of the system and hopefully
the ag engineers uh will figure this out
and make this work and i know that this
has been a challenge for a number of
years so this is this is by no means uh
uh uh a piece of machinery that's farm
ready vegetable ready yes this would
work great in vegetable systems but
we're just working with pelletized
poultry litter because pellets are are
really easy to work with they behave as
far as decomposition kinetics very
identical practically to to bulk litter
and so from a behavioral standpoint it's
a let's test our questions but we're
able to put out very precise uniform
rates and
we're able to
abandon this poultry litter and the
machine we built allows us to apply it
at side dress
so whether or not side dressing poultry
litter is going to become a regularly
adopted practice or the focus is still
going to be pre-plant there's lots of
logistical constraints actually side
dressing corn with poultry litter then
then just coming in at planting and
just a lot of management issues but
this is uh we wanted to continue to test
that question of use efficiency where
we're side dressing our poultry litter
and take advantage of the types of
management practices we know
work with with mineral fertilizers and
so this is what that looks like here
we've got coulter cutting a trench
that's slightly skewed uh
it's on an angle and so it creates a
little trench as it drives through the
field and poultry litter shot right down
into that trench and then these clothing
wheels close that up and i kid you not
you walk into a field a couple weeks
later you don't even know where this
unit went i mean the residue is all
covered up you can't see the the
disturbance and you and you've just
dropped down
we can drop down up up you know anywhere
from uh three-quarters to
uh you know
five or six tons of poultry litter in an
application rate with this machine
so this generated several research
questions that link to this these cover
crop mixtures that that i'm going to
present on uh and so some of the
questions that came out of this is just
you know you know how does you know side
dressing this unit work can we can it
will will it will it affect the
decomposition of the surface residues
that we're getting a lot of benefits
from um and and how does it
distribute it to the soil profile and
how does it behave over time i'm only
going to give you just a little glimpse
of this work we had a lot of
work testing this question across a
suite of different management treatments
we're only going to look at a very
subset of them so now this is
the additional methodology but we're
only targeting specific cover crops so
just the monocultures and the mixture
and
we put down poultry litter in various
different application methods where we
broadcast it on the surface and it
which is a typical practice historically
where just put your poultry right over
that cover crop
or
apply it over the surface and
incorporate it and manage like a tillage
based system organic site we managed it
organically as you would tillage the
conventional was just a chisel till uh
conventional
tillage based system and then we have
all these subsurface banded treatments
where we put subsurface banding at
different rates and uh and then we have
a no manure application and so
i'm going to talk about a little bit of
this if you have more questions about
some of the treatments that i mentioned
here certainly approach me later in the
day uh so to understand just how that
nitrogen is being released and you'll be
able to quantify uh the availability of
nitrogen now we have this whole spatial
issue we've got to deal with we've taken
a broadcast rate and we've narrowed it
down to these little bands
so the the types of questions you have
to ask related to how you would take a
soil sample and and test the the release
rates of nitrogen and what is available
uh became a whole research thrust into
itself it was quite fun so here we we
actually are doing depth structured
spatial cores over the growing season of
corn to see how that nitrogen is moving
and so this is what a core would look
like this is the band
and these are the number of soil cores
that we've taken across that band and
then you know this it's a mirror image
to the left and to the right of that
band and so then those are compiled
together and analyzed for inorganic
nitrogen content
and then also we segmented these into
these different depths
so we have a pretty good uh resolution
of nitrogen in that soil profile
and so then we developed a spatial model
to assess nitrogen in moving from that
band and so that had to both
incorporate the band effect the cover
crop effect and the residual spatial
dependence and i could give a whole talk
just on this model and what we had to do
so i'm going to just be really quick
this is a diffusion model we're using
euclidean distances to estimate
uh
nitrogen across that spatial profile
and and and this is what that model
looks like there's a fair number of
other steps involved in in
in this model to get to this point but
this is the pretty picture we want to
look at to get a sense of how nitrogen
is behaving spatially this is just one
site year this doesn't include all of
the other fertility treatments this is
just the poultry litter ban that went
down at side dress and that's our rye
our hairy vetch and that's our mixture
so these are just our three cover crops
at five different growth stages of corn
and the band is done at side dress so
this is just the effects of the cover
crop
and then as you see over time the
movement of the of the nitrogen away
from that ban and what i think is the
most startling from our results
the nitrogen doesn't move very much
it doesn't move very much at all we were
expecting
all sorts of of issues related to
vertical and horizontal movement that we
would have to build into these spatial
models the reality of it is is that a
lot of this nitrogen is becoming
available when the corn is starting to
grow rapidly and we see tremendous root
proliferation around the band
and so the nitrogen is actually being
taken up almost as rapidly as it's being
mineralized from that poultry litter
band and so you're seeing very little
movement away from the band
and what's more just coming back to that
other figure now
what was really interesting is that we
saw no difference from sub-surface
banding versus you know no poultry
litter whatsoever on the effects of
cover crop decay
so not only are we getting very
localized nitrogen when we ban that
poultry litter and and not a lot of
movement from the band but we're getting
no impacts on the decay of our cover
crops on the surface and that's really
important because when we're trying to
manage our system and we're trying to
know what our variables are
the more interactions we have with our
management the more challenging it is to
make decisions so being able to know
what's going on with the nitrogen in the
soil and know that that's not having the
same implications on on nitrogen or or
mulch decay
allows us to make more precise
recommendations or farmers to make
better decisions about their management
so summary of these findings
surface-banded poultry litter
applications did not affect
decomposition as i mentioned
in fact all of this is really just a
review of what i just said
so i'm going to just give you another
little taste of some of the supplemental
work we did around this this is just one
more piece of data so on top of all this
we've created these this continuum of
cover crops and nitrogen availability
and and nitrogen source in the landscape
we you know we have all these different
mineral sources and manure sources and
cover crops so
we know that that has a lot of
implications on n2o emissions coming
from uh the
soil and and and certainly corn is one
of our biggest players in n2o emissions
uh so it's it's certainly an important
place to test this question and so
i didn't really realize what i was
getting into when we started this
research but uh
greenhouse gas measurements and n2o is
quite labor intensive and exhausting uh
and most of the expertise that was
involved in guiding my graduate student
and myself is coming from michelle
cavagelli who has been doing kind of
greenhouse gas emissions and beltsville
for a very long time
um so here are the frames that we use
that they they span the distance from
cornrow to cornrow
and this is just an example of a
sampling event we do this year round
anytime it rains we're out there whether
it's friday saturday sunday whatever day
of the week it is
holidays if it rains we're out there the
next day
sampling because that's what's driving
n2o emissions and so just to give you a
little taste of what that looks like so
now what you're looking at is different
rates of poultry litter applied and and
so this is our tillage treatment so this
is and this these rates just to kind of
cue you in this is what we consider our
p base rate so kind of nitrogen applied
at the p removal uh level and then this
135 is really our our nitrogen typical
nitrogen base rate and then this is
rates that we apply that are actually
not untypical in in
delmarva at all but but uh uh it
represents our kind of our saturated
nitrogen levels so we're uh for either a
very low fertile site or or um
just to help us you know have an
asymptote in the in the data sets that
we're looking at and then this nine
kilograms is just because in the in some
of these organic systems we're actually
been experimenting with just putting
down some pellets at planting so we're
actually running the the fertilizer
boxes the dry fertilizer box is open and
dropping pelletized poultry litter at
planting and we're getting about uh 500
pounds of poultry put down at that point
that kind of gives you a rough
equivalent of a plant available nitrogen
that's coming so this is a nitrogen
gradient here of of application rate and
this is just uh
this is basically no-till and this is
till
and what we also have in there is our
bare ground and then of course across
this axis is our bare ground our rye our
mixture and our hairy vetch
this is a this is pooled for two years
so we didn't have a year interaction
this is two complete years of greenhouse
gas measurements measured i mean
sometimes you know in the upwards of 90
to 120 measurements in a year
and so this is a fairly uh comprehensive
look at how our fertility and our cover
crop management drives greenhouse gases
and clearly the things that stand out
obviously is that you have more nitrogen
in the system you're going to get more
n2o emissions that's not rocket science
um what should be interesting to you is
that the bare ground really comes down
as the as having the least n2o emissions
and there's a number of reasons
obviously there's there's not some of
the presence of of carbon coming from
sources of cover crops carbon is a very
important component of of n2o uh uh
release and and creating the conditions
for and and to oh production but then
also your the soil dries out quite a bit
more you know when you have a cover crop
on the surface you retain soil moisture
levels much higher which are our more
conducive conditions environment for uh
greenhouse gas emissions but what was
really interesting was that when you
look at the amount of nitrogen applied
in the form of poultry litter with the
amount of nitrogen losses n2o
while sure the bare ground has its
advantages from from from the standpoint
of lower n2o but there's also other
implications of having you know ground
that dries out and and not having those
carbon amendments going back in but
clearly
the mixtures shine
we get a cover crop that can both supply
the nitrogen for the cash crop
it has a slower release rate and it also
reduces our n2o emissions
as a function of fertilizer applied
so again cover crops can increase into
emissions
uh generally uh they respond in an
exponential way although you were
looking at log transform data sets
and we have some you know future plans
of following up some of this work in
these systems some additional
measurements
you only caught a little glimmer of
these data sets and and what we're kind
of pulling together and so kind of the
next phase of this is to kind of do some
multi-criteria assessments of these
systems looking at the various different
factors and how they interact and kind
of building a more uh complete data set
and also part of the work that we're
doing here is working closely with jeff
in in some of the models that he's
developing and that's been a really fun
collaboration
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu